I want you to live the life you were
meant to live you hear me not the life
that was given to you I'm a high school
dropout cuz that's the life my daddy
gave
me but I've been married almost 28 years
and two kids by the same woman which is
not my experience I got brothers and
sisters none of us had the same
parents because I made up in my mind
that's the life y'all gave me humans do
not transition to another level when
they comfortable with the level that
they're on you only go to another level
when you on this level and you eating
out of trash cans and you say enough is
enough when you living in abandoned
buildings in the winter and you say
enough is enough you only transition
from one level to the next when you
tired of the level you are